hello everyone
welcome to pi data global this is
building a successful
data science team my name is justin
nguyen
and if you've seen any of my previous
talks or
other conference presentations i usually
talk about
nlp pipelines and custom feature
extraction
and unsupervised topic modeling today
i'm going to go in a different direction
first i'm going to talk about cooking
yes
i know what you're thinking and you are
correct the fish on the left
did turn into the fish tacos on the
right the second thing i'm going to talk
about
is my more recent work which is helping
organizations build
or rebuild their data science teams and
you might be wondering whoa whoa cooking
building a data science team
they seem like they're very very
different
but they're not you see cooking and
building a
data science team have a lot in common
first there's a lot of people trying to
do it
but do they really understand
what and why they're doing it do they
understand
each component each ingredient the
flavor the texture the aroma
as well as how everything comes together
and connects
into a cohesive harmony a second
like any great dish is that you rarely
get it right on your first try
the same goes for building a great data
science team if you are nailing it on
your first try
then you should consider yourself one of
the very very few
and one of the very very lucky
and finally a great dish has a lot of
steps
it has a lot of ingredients and you
don't pop in the microwave for 90
minutes
it takes time the same goes
for building a great data science team
they require a lot of pieces to be in
place
within the data science team and beyond
the data science team
they require more than just a smart data
scientist or two
and they aren't built overnight
now it may seem like i'm making
successful data science sound really
really difficult
well that's because it is over 8 out of
10 data science projects
never make it to production most of the
data science projects that you
do most of the data science teams that
you build
are not destined to succeed
the odds are stacked against us and why
is this
why are so few data science teams
successful
based on the teams that i've studied the
teams that i've worked with
i'm going to share three things that are
really distinguish
the successful versus the not so
successful data science teams
those three things are building the
right team picking the right use cases
in rapid technical enablement
so let's get started with building the
right team
before we talk about the people let's
first establish what we are trying to do
if we want to define the positions and
draft the players
let's first align on what we're trying
to achieve
and successful data science
as we have all learned by now goes
beyond just the hyper parameter tuning
it goes beyond the iterative development
cycles and sprints
beyond chris dm successful
data science requires success beyond
data science it requires you
to find a feasible and value opportunity
that hasn't been fulfilled
it requires due diligence and validating
some insight it requires lots of
accurate and accessible data
and so forth it requires a lot of
components and these are
really difficult challenges that you
have to get right
you have to be successful at every one
of these toll gates or else your project
will not be successful
you can't ignore or fail any one of
these
steps and still have success at the end
fortunately for most of us i think
we've realized that data science teams
are more than just data scientists
which brings us to a more holistic
approach
that uh that i've examined where we have
now thankfully
much more of a balance rather than ask
your data scientist to do
everything under the sun now
unlike before we're allowing them to
focus on what they're good at
by adding other people and adding other
skill sets
and this is a good thing it's a good
step
in the right direction we're adding
subject matter expertise
and experience we're adding executive
engagement
and we're adding communication because
going back
and mapping these to the process this is
what we need to be successful this
divide and conquer
is much better much more efficient much
more successful
than having one person or one type of
person like your data scientist
trying to accomplish all of this on
their own
now you might be looking at this
template and think this is great
i wish we could fill out my data science
team like this
with these kinds of resources and all
this expertise
and you're right i mean this this has
worked well for me in the past
and ultimately it's a recipe that works
but just like any recipe you can follow
it
and still get it wrong how does that
happen
well it happens when you don't
understand the recipe
you need to understand what every step
does what every component
is supposed to do in order for
everything to come together
at the end so let me first start with
these three roles
these are all great roles and great
people to have on your team
based on their responsibilities within
the company they have access
to a lot of very very valuable and
crucial resources
they have access to experience and data
and other expertise that you will need
but that's still not enough the really
successful
data science teams that i've seen have
people who do
more than just serve in these roles
they deliver resources but they also
deliver results
and how do they do that well they
assume their role they own their role
but they also leverage some exceptional
quality that they have and this quality
isn't
a job title it's some intrinsic
and natural talent that they're known
for
we all know someone or have someone
in our organization who is an
exceptional storyteller innovator or
leader
they're very very hard to find and
probably a pain in the butt to get your
hands on
and so these people probably aren't
sitting around and waiting for you
to ask them to join their data science
team right
but if and when
you can combine these qualities on the
right
with the resources on the left that
is what makes this recipe work
because going back to this data science
process
just imagine you position your top
innovators and leaders and storytellers
and drop them into key steps when you
meet them
where you must be successful well that's
how you leverage your ingredients
this is how and why this recipe
works
so let's talk about the other two roles
here data scientists and data engineers
and
i'm sorry i'm going to be honest with
you guys i don't have any shortcuts or
secrets
to getting around the recruiting and
hiring headache
except for this when you're getting
recruited
every week by at least three new
companies every week
you start catching on and figuring out
how to tell and distinguish between them
it's very apparent which ones are mature
organizations that will allow you to do
data science and engineering
versus which ones where you'll be a
one-man band
and just pass the torch to yourself
it's very obvious where you'll be
successful
and if it's not obvious then that's
probably because you're a recruiter not
a data scientist
now my advice is to set up your data
science team in a way
that attracts great talent
great data scientists want to be great
at data science
great data engineers want to be great at
data engineering
both want to be successful so this
process this support system this
collection of
diverse resources and skills
allows them to do that if i'm a hotshot
data scientist or engineer and you ask
me to join a team
with other great data scientists and
engineers
and innovators and great leaders and
storytellers
well that's joining a recipe for success
so let's move on to the second
topic for today um
and uh and i want to talk about cooking
for a date and i mean a date date not
your
spouse or kids but someone you're really
trying
to impress so what starts going through
your mind well the first thing
you'll probably ask yourself is what can
i cook well
if you're like me this is a very easy
question to answer because this list is
very short
the second thing you ask is what will
impress and if you're like me again
this list will be very short now
remember this is a date date so
first impressions go a long way so you
need an early win
and you want to make it a double one you
want to impress
the other thing so cooking for a date
is just one of those things where
there's a lot that can go wrong
right it's one of those things in life
where you have a very very
limited number of paths to success
and a seemingly limitless number of
paths to failure
so for example maybe you decide that i
have
nothing in my arsenal that will impress
so i need to try something completely
new
something that you've never made before
well this is really risky
and i don't know who needs to hear this
but your odds of success are not
that good another thing that can happen
is that you aim for perfection so uh you
start
for example to overthink or overdo what
you're making
and as a result you make things worse
and then last is insufficient planning
so
you forgot to check the pantry for
ingredients
you forgot to plan dessert you forgot
she had a
shellfish allergy the list goes on
you get the point the point is that
there's a lot to think about
and there's a lot that can go wrong
picking a data science use case is like
cooking for a date
first you ask yourself what can i cook
well or what is highly feasible
what data technology expertise resources
do i have
and then you also ask what will impress
or what is most valuable
which use cases will deliver the most
value also same rule applies
first impressions go a long way so your
early wins
need to be double wins and then the same
pitfalls
apply you can try something completely
new
and outside of your wheelhouse you can
build r2d2 or an ironman suit
but that's pretty risky um
another pitfall is aiming for perfection
right
and data science data science is about
progression
not perfection so aiming for the perfect
machine learning model is a really great
way to bankrupt yourself and waste a lot
of time
and then finally insufficient planning
and this is the most common pitfall that
i see
the success of your use cases will be
determined by
your planning planning your use cases
is where companies often trip and they
don't get their value out of data
science
so how do you plan well for starters
go back to those questions determine
first what is highly feasible
i often call this the art of the
possible and this means gathering
leaders from across
the organization and brainstorming all
the possibilities
all of the pain points all of the nice
to haves and this sounds tedious but
it's really not it gives people an
opportunity to be heard and to share
their ideas on how to improve the
business
and usually these discussions are a lot
of fun
once you determine the art of the
possible now you want to prioritize them
into the art of the valuable you want to
rank these based on the measurable
value that they return now
again your use your early wins need to
be double wins so prioritize
use cases that will impress your
organizations
or your customers
now um let's say you go through all
these
all these steps and now you have your
use cases picked
i want to talk about a step that often
gets skipped even though it makes a huge
difference
so a lot of data science projects start
with this quote and we've all heard it
before
we have all this data what can we do
with it
so what do we do well as data scientists
we go to work right
we acquire the data we start analyzing
and developing and then at the end
we try to derive or summon the value
that we can get
out of what we just did
but there's a couple of problems with
this approach so first
we often don't get a chance to finish
our work
we're heads down we're working and maybe
we get close to the end but then we get
pulled into something else
there's another problem that requires
our skill set
the second thing that often happens is
confusion so stakeholders they get
confused
or maybe we get confused on what we're
trying to achieve or deliver
and that's bad because confusion kills
momentum
we talked earlier about evangelism and
storytelling well
we can't get buy-in from outside of the
data science team
if there's confusion or zero energy
point being the likelihood of success
for whatever this use case
is is very very slim
a better approach is to spend more time
planning up front now you still need to
do the other steps you still need to
acquire the data
and analyze and develop and so forth but
before you do you do two things
the first is you identify and study the
actual problem or pain point that you're
that you're solving and then the second
is you establish your kpis up front
by doing a little bit more planning here
at the beginning it resolves the two
issues we saw earlier so first it
protects you
from the scope changing now we know what
we're focusing on
before anyone tries to import pandas or
sk learn
and then second and eliminates the
confusion by setting very clear
goals that we are marching towards goals
that can be communicated
and goals that everyone is aware of this
is a very very simple step
and it solves a lot of headache down the
road
so after you do your due diligence and
planning and you finally hit the ground
running it's time to start executing
your use cases
by now we all know that data science is
very different than your traditional and
slow-moving i.t
for example traditional i.t is
heavily focused on minimizing risk
whereas data science is very risky
and focused heavily on rapid
experimentation
good data scientists will fail fast and
deliver
rapid and incremental wins
a lot of the dues versus don'ts on here
go back to some of the themes we talked
about earlier
and to summarize it's donate for don't
aim
for perfection aim for progression and
make sure you're focused on delivering
value
build what will impress your business or
customers
this brings us to the third and final
topic for today
rapid technical enablement so
i'm going to assume that by now we've
all realized that data science teams
need loads of data and databases and
compute and tools and so forth so i'm
not going to talk about those
instead i'm going to talk about going
beyond that
in other ways that you can empower your
data science team so
another way of phrasing this is uh the
question i want to address is
how do i support my data science teams
and this is a very non-trivial question
right
i mean everyone is trying to poach
everyone so how
how do you be successful while also
retaining and keeping your folks
happy so
there's an author speechwriter and
lawyer named daniel pink he studied
a bunch of successful technical teams
and he came up with this theory that i
think works really well for data science
teams
it's basically that high achieving
individuals are driven to pursue
three things mastery autonomy
and purpose so let me start with mastery
good data scientists always want to grow
data science is constantly evolving and
you need to evolve with it
there's your data science team have that
access
to grow and evolve are there a wide
range of experts to learn from
do your data scientists get to attend
webinars and conferences
like pi data are they involved in user
groups and so forth
or are they uh the one-man band that we
talked about earlier are they siloed
um are they always just constantly
working
and putting out fires without having
the time to invest in themselves
the next is autonomy and this is really
about
ownership so one thing i like to tell
people on my team is that
you have 51 percent of the vote or
decision
but 100 of the accountability
meaning that you ultimately decide on
the strategy
the tactics and the how but you also
own the outcome it almost becomes
personal
and it's no secret that if you're
completely responsible for the outcome
you're going to make sure the outcome is
pretty dang good
and then the last is purpose so we all
want to do impactful work that makes a
difference
and we all know that we should establish
and communicate this purpose
the thing that we forget is that we
forget
especially when you're a data scientist
or engineer
it's just it's very easy to lose track
of what
you're doing all this for and so don't
forget to remind your teens
and bring them back out of the shadows
so anyway this is an overview of of
mastery autonomy and purpose it's a good
guide and barometer to gauge
how you can support your data science
teams
um and really ask yourself are you
giving them all three
of uh of these things because if you are
you're in a good spot you're you're
better than most
um but if we go back to the question of
supporting data science teams especially
kind of that data science specific
component
there's two more things that uh that
i've noticed and i want to call out
the first is creating the experience
which is
something i see data science teams
struggle with a lot
so we're going to go back to cooking for
a second
if you're a practical person like me
you've probably wondered
why pay so much for a restaurant
a twenty dollar rack of lamb at a
grocery store is at least
seventy dollars at a restaurant and it's
a rack of lamb right
i mean you look on the left and it's
already just a great piece of meat
the only difference between the picture
on the left
and the picture on the right is 20
minutes on the grill
20 minutes
as data science teams we often produce
this great
model or great insight but what's
missing
is that last 20 minutes it's that
narrative it's that experience
it's that last 20 minutes on the grill
which is what people pay a lot of money
for
and i don't mean diagrams or knowledge
graph projections or topic modeling
visualizations or ides or even
word clouds or whatever charts graphs
whatever
i mean this
mark one introduce yourself
hello i'm a combination of mobile ai and
spark technologies
i was built by justin when in early
2019.
so far my eye includes an lp computer
vision and data analysis
i can be programmed and trained to do
almost anything
speaking from experience this is what
your business or customers will pay for
they may want or ask for data science or
insights but what they really want is
the narrative
and the experience and for those of you
who are familiar with mobile programming
this has very little to do with data
science
all this is this is just the last 20
minutes on the grill
and this is something that every data
science team
needs
the last thing that every great data
science team needs
is a servant leader so vince lombardi
once said the importance of
he wants to emphasize the importance of
blocking and tackling
i'm here to tell you that this applies
in data science as well
your data scientists and engineers are
very very talented they're very very
skilled and this means
that they're going to be pulled in many
different directions
and these are going to be directions
that they may not want to be pulled in
or shouldn't be pulled into
so if you want your data science team to
deliver
great data science you need to block and
tackle for them
so let's wrap this up we talked about
three things today
uh building the right team picking the
right use cases and technical
enablement so some closing thoughts
first
make sure you fill the right roles on
your team
and understand the parts they play
you need resources as well as skill sets
don't just follow the recipe but develop
a deep understanding for it
second is pick your use cases very
wisely
and make sure you plan plan plan
just like cooking for a date first
impressions matter
so focus on delivering value quickly
and then last is give your data science
teams mastery autonomy and purpose
that's a great start
but once you have that established give
them more
lead them to deliver that full
experience and narrative that your
business or customers
will pay a lot of money for and then
also make sure that you
block and tackle for them along the way
i'd like to thank all of you for
attending my talk today
if you're interested in learning more or
if you want to discuss any of the
uh the techniques or the dishes that i
spoke of today please feel free to reach
out
that's all i had for today until next
time enjoy the rest of the conference